la patience est de mise aux urgences
cinq médecins sur huit étaient absents
ce matin
conséquence de la grève que mènent les
urgentistes depuis deux semaines ils
protestent contre la présence de
patients dans les couloirs de leur
service des malades qu'ils restent
parfois plusieurs heures voire dix jours
sur des brancards
avec tous les risques que cela comporte
ça veut dire qu'ils sont pas en sécurité
c'est pas sont là ils sont en danger
dans les couloirs parce qu'on peut pas
les surveiller on peut pas les soigner
on peut pas leur donner à manger pas
donne à boire on peut pas du tout dépend
charente au sécurité pour la direction
du chu de la martinique
une solution est à l'étude pour trouver
des chambres aux patients et pour
désengorger les couloirs des urgences
on a mis en place un staff le matin donc
une réunion où les urgentistes
rencontrait les médecins des étages et
en fait il se répartissaient des
patients en fonction des différentes
spécialités et puis là on est en train
de creuser une autre solution c'est à
dire que finalement quand il ya vraiment
trop de patients aux urgences ne voit en
fait comment finalement ce serait plus
les urgences qui gérerait ses patients
mais une autre équipe
les urgences sont débordées au regard de
la situation il est préférable que vous
fassiez appel aux maisons médicales à
sos médecins ou aux 15 pour laisser aux
urgences les cas les plus sensibles
le mouvement de grève se poursuit